[Musique]
dans leur décision de devenir
indépendant financièrement le couple a
ri et mégane renault à leur part de
location royal qui représente 5 % de
leurs revenus
il pourrait aussi abandonner une partie
des fonds qui leur donne le prince
charles regard ce soir sur la structure
financière de la famille royale avec
patrick taillon professeur à la faculté
de droit de l'université laval à québec
bonsoir monsieur taillon bonsoir
alors tout de go je vous pose la
question très simplement quels sont les
revenus de la famille royale
oui d'abord comme toutes corporations
comme toute institution il faut
distinguer deux patrimoines
il ya les deux corps du roi si je peux
dire donc il ya le patrimoine de la
couronne qui au fond si nadine ici du
patrimoine de l'état
il ya des patrimoines personnel qui
appartient à l'individu
le patrimoine de l'état est la reine car
tellement elle peut pas léguer à peux
pas me léguer ses biens et ses biens il
reste propriété de l'état et dans le
patrimoine privé
il ya des biens qu'elle pourrait vous
léguez elle pourrait mêler les gays ou
les léguer n'importe qui donc dans le
patrimoine de la couronne n'a pas de
patrimoine de l'état
on parle d'à peu près une valeur de 15
milliards en dollars canadiens de bien
et c'est un patrimoine est tellement
vaste qu'on est guéri
oui on a même créé une société publique
l'équivalent de la caisse de dépôt et de
placement si vous voulez une société de
gestion publique avec un conseil
d'administration pour faire fructifier
le plus possible ce 15 milliards de
dollars
donc ce patrimoine génère des revenus
oui le 15 milliards approximatif génère
annuellement des revenus de placement
des revenus immobiliers de toutes sortes
et là dessus selon là sans la générosité
de l'économie la générosité de ses
placements
on va retenir 15 à 25% pour payer ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le coût de
fonctionnement de la famille royale
britannique donc la vda il ya des
salaires à des employés des salaires aux
membres de famille
du coup il ya du personnel a
probablement autour de plus de 400
employés de l'entretien maintenir des
châteaux dans un état habitable est chez
terreur chez terra et il leur reste donc
au moins 75 % des revenus générés par la
société crown estate la société d'état
l'équivalent la caisse de dépôt et de
placement va retourner dans le trésor
public
donc ça c'est le volet patrimoine privé
dans lequel avec le temps il ya des
jeunes y avait parfois des frontières du
silence qui privé public mais disons que
si le volet qu'on pourrait appeler plus
patrimoine de la couronne à ça s'ajoute
parce qu'évidemment la famille royale
elle reçoit comme une forme de salaire
dans tout ça
ce salaire va dans leur patrimoine privé
de personnes physiques et ça ce
patrimoine privé là bas c'est davantage
à leur discrétion et l'on va retrouver
dans ce patrimoine d'autres biais par
exemple le château de balmoral et sap
pour la reine c'est pas un bien qui
appartient au patrimoine de la couronne
public là c'est un patrimoine c'est un
jeu c'est quand même un appartement
personnel elle pourrait le légué à sa
mort à qui elle veut il retourne pas
dans le patrimoine de l'état
donc pour c'est bien là c'est un peu
plus compliqué si tu m'aimais mais on
peut penser que la génération de
elizabeth ii son mari le prince charles
on parle d'à peu près des montants de
l'ordre de plusieurs centaines de
millions canadiens
oui comme valeur de patrimoine puis pour
la nouvelle génération là le prince
william le prince harry
on est dans des patrimoines autour de
quelques dizaines de millions de dollars
canadiens qui s'est un peu l'ordre de
grandeur si je peux dire quand on parle
donc on parle de patrimoine on parle d'
actifs d'actifs publics d'actifs privés
il ya en marge de cela à partir de cela
il ya des revenus de plusieurs millions
de dollars qui sont versés à la reine
qui sont versés au prince charles qui
sont versés au prince william et au
prince harry est également oui mais elle
partie des revenus qui dans le cas du
patrimoine public sont aussi reverser à
l'état et c'est un peu normal qu'on
connaît une une monarchie ou une
république il y a dans ses biens
dans le volet plus public il ya des
châteaux si demain matin les
britanniques abolissent la monarchie on
va quand même vouloir générer des
revenus avec ses châteaux et on va quand
même vouloir les entretenir
donc c'est ça qui est très très
difficile de séparer vraiment le privé
puis le public dans un tel régime il ya
pas mal de dépenses aussi faute villes
qui sont associées aux activités de la
famille royale ou et toute forme
d'institution génère des dépenses qu'on
a un régime présidentiel ou un régime
monarchique
mais c'est clair qu'il ya un espèce de
de luxe qui accompagnent la famille
royale ne serait ce que parce qu'on veut
que les châteaux dans bien des cas
restent des résidences habitable et donc
il ya un certain coût qui entoure tout
ça il ya un coût en terme de personnel
aussi qui entoure la monarchie donc
personnel d'entretien de services mais
aussi de l' expertise en communication
des conseillers politiques des aides de
toutes sortes
donc ça c'est beaucoup de dépenses de la
représentation des oeuvres de charité
mais aussi des missions à l'étranger qui
parfois sont en partie payé par les pays
que l'on visite et parfois sont payés
par le trésor britannique
les contribuables britanniques paient
aussi pour les activités officielles de
rennes
une partie des biens de l'état et les
biens du
de la famille royale dans son volet les
biens de la couronne c'est un peu la
même chose c'est le même patrimoine
ce que je veux dire c'est que sur les
impôts que les britanniques fait est ce
qu'une petite part au savoir à la
famille royale maman compréhension c'est
que le 15 à 25% générés par le le la
société qui gère les patrimoines suffit
à à payer la vaste majorité des frais
bon après on essaye parfois de faire une
équivalence ya des gens qui mentionne un
coût qui serait quelques centièmes en
dehors canadien à peu près à peu près un
dollar canadien par habitant mais ça
devient compliqué parce que les revenus
sont générés à partir de biens qui
appartiennent à l'état britannique une
partie sont détournés vers les activités
de la famille royale puis le reste reste
dans le trésor public il nous reste une
minute quels sont les revenus que
conserveront aroui et mégane s'il
renonce d'une part à leurs revenus
publics patrimoine de la couronne qui
déménage au canada alors il renonce à ce
qu'ils représentaient pour eux 5 % de
leurs revenus qui venait du volet public
par contre le prince charles à des
douches et qui lui appartient qui génère
l'essentiel des revenus de cette
génération lol de prince harry du prince
william soit il voudrait
il voudrait en conserver une part s'est
pas encore résolu ensuite de ça ils
veulent gagner leur vie à leur manière
donc on peut penser qu'ils vont
commencer à chercher à générer des
revenus à partir de leurs noms leurs
marques leurs activités et à partir de
ça ils vont se constituer leur
patrimoine à eux et là se pose la
question fondamentale pour nous ici père
de taxes au québec et au canada
qui va payer pour leur sécurité durant
la partie de l'année où ils vont résider
au canada alors on attend la réponse à
cela prochainement patrick taillon merci
beaucoup c'était très clair c'est moi
qui vous remercie
au revoir